ptete d'arbres on voit le ciel à travers
il ya des crosnes fenêtres on voit qu'il
va pas bien les chaînes ont une durée de
vie de cent cinquante ans c'est l'âge ou
en forêt privée
on va exploiter ces arbres dans cette
forêt de 40 hectares d'un propriétaire
privé
le constat est sans appel des arbres
malades à cause du réchauffement
climatique
une forêt de chênes qui agonise
lentement ces chaînes ont un problème
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à suivre
l'évolution du climat
ce sont des chaînes qui s'appelle chêne
pédonculé qui ont besoin de beaucoup de
lumière et d'eau et on a des grandes
périodes de sécheresse et il n'arrive
plus à traverser ces périodes de
sécheresse une sécheresse
il arrive à résister 2 3 4 et au bout
d'un certain nombre ils n'arrivent plus
à résister non plus la capacité de
rejaillir de rebondir et il meurt comme
tout organisme qui s'épuise qui sait
puisque ces puits et va vers la mort et
c'est là que l'association duras mais
n'intervient il faut replanter mais pas
n'importe comment
grâce à un financement participatif sur
internet
ils ont récolté 5000 euros pour aider
les propriétaires à reboiser leurs
parcelles il faut replanter des arbres
qui soit adaptée aux changements
climatiques et l'objectif de durham n
c'est d'aider les propriétaires
forestiers à replanter parce que
finalement quand ils coupent leurs
arbres ils ont très peu de revenus les
propriétaires forestiers
il faut les aider ils ont besoin de plus
d'argent pour finalement réinvestir et
planter de nouveaux arbres
l'association du ramène espère récolter
de 6000 à 10 mille euros pour replanter
entre 3 et 5 hectares de forêt